.
Gabrielle Proulx.
- Avec
de Kyoto le 11 décembre 1997,
pourprprpremière fois, des pays
industrialisés s'entendent sur
la
à effet de serre.
- Deux membres de Greenpeace
n'ont pas hésité à escalad t t r
une bannière, protestanttrtrtre
le réchauffement de la planète.
écologistes, dont Steven
Guilbeault aujourd'hui ministre
un geste d'éclat en escaladant
la tour du CN.
STÉPHANE DI
de l'Environnement (2004-2005)
- Le gouvernement pense que
Kyoto est bon pour les
Canadiens.
qu'en 2002 pour s'en retirer
dix ans plus tard.
PETER KENT, ministre fédéral de
l'Environnement (2011-2013)
- De n..........................
- Steven Guilbeault faisait
d'eueueurs partie de
la délégation canadienne
à Kyoto au Japon.eteteteteteteta
- L'"écolo-granol" que je suis,
il savait pas trop quoi faire
avec moi sur sa délégation,
mais je lui ai dit : Monsieur
proposer un paragraphe qui nous
permet de revoir, en fonction de
la science, les objectifs."
Il se tourne vers ses
conseillers, et sentntntntntntn"
- 25 ans plus tard, le Canada
n'a respecté aucune de ses
cibles. Entre 2015 et 2019,
les émissiont t t t t t t t t te
723 à 730 mégatonnes;
contrairement aux autres pays
du G7 qui ont vu une diminution
durant la même période.
BABABAA KHAN, DG pour le Québect
l'Atl., Fondation David Suzuki
de travail à faire pour régler
l'incohérence entrsss
politiques environnementales et
nos politiques économiques.
de l'environnement considère
Kyoto comme omomoment charnière
dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique.
Inst. sciences environ., UQAM
- Çcococommencé dès, on pourrait
dire, la fin des années 70,
même le début des an
où les changements climatiques
sont passés d'une problématique
juste scientifique à vraiment
et politique.
- Là où Kyoto aurait échoué,
selon lui, ce serait de ne pas
comme la Chine et l'Inde,
en plus des États-Unis qui
produisent maintenant 65 % des
serre sur la planète